you are about to witness a prophecy of
Islam come true right before your eyes
so we've been driving for about six
hours we caught a flight in the morning
for an hour but humbly we were finally
here where the village of the Himba
people they are an indigenous people who
seclude themselves from the outside
world
holy fire is the place where they go and
worship to the ancestors when they see
when it rains when they needs all the
other blessing the men only covered the
lower parts of their body and the women
didn't cover their bodies either a stuff
for Allah abdurraheem how dare you guys
give Islam to naked people let me remind
you at the time of the Prophet
sallallahu alayhi wasallam
people used to do tow off around the
Kaaba completely naked did The Messenger
of Allah stop or did he continue giving
dower
these people deserve to learn about
Allah and we believe God is only one god
we all come from different places in the
world our faith Islam unites us all we
shared the beautiful and simple message
of Islam our belief in one God the
Creator and how simple it was the tribes
chief he told them if you believe and
understand what our guests are saying
and find it to be the truth then feel
free to accept it
Allah Akbar the chief had done the job
for us they got up and testified to what
we had explained to them
[Music]
the Himba tribe live in cone-shaped
holes made for mud trees and cattle dung
the village was literally as the prophet
sallallahu alayhi wasallam described
this matter of Islam will reach where
the night and day have reached and it
will not leave a house of mud or a house
of except Allah will bring it into this
deen the guide if you can see this
modern ahead is because we just did our
salah in front of them and for some of
these people it was the first to do that
they did to this tribe in the middle of
nowhere
look how love what islam to them guided
them to the straight path and now
they've made their first started as well
click the button and donate now and
please please please don't forget to
share this video it's free and you would
also share in the reward of others
donating for free
[Music]